su corazón es una máquina extraordinaria
durante su vida las paredes musculares
del corazón bombea en sangre a los vasos
sanguíneos que se esparcen por todo el
cuerpo
su corazón tiene cuatro cámaras dos
cámaras superiores llamadas aurícula
derecha e izquierda
y dos cámaras inferiores llamadas
ventrículo derecho e izquierdo se
contraen en un ritmo estable conocido
como latidos del corazón durante un
latido normal del corazón la sangre de
sus tejidos y pulmones fluye en sus
aurículas
y luego en sus ventrículos
las paredes dentro de su corazón
llamadas tabique inter atrial e
interventricular ayudan a impedir que la
sangre de los lados izquierdo y derecho
se mezclen
dos válvulas funcionan como puertas
entre las aurículas y los ventrículos
para impedir que la sangre fluya hacia
atrás en las aurículas la válvula
tricúspide se abre en su ventrículo
derecho
y la válvula bicúspide también conocida
como la válvula mitral se abre en su
ventrículo izquierdo
y los tejidos delgados pero fuertes
llamados cuerdas tendinosas sostienen a
las válvulas en su lugar durante las
contracciones efectivas de sus
ventrículos
y la sangre que sale de los ventrículos
pasa por otro conjunto de válvulas la
válvula pulmonar entre el ventrículo
derecho y la arteria pulmonar y la
válvula aórtica conectando la aorta y el
ventrículo izquierdo
con el fin de bombear la sangre con
mayor eficiencia su músculo del corazón
llamado miocardio está dispuesto
siguiendo un patrón único tres capas del
miocardio envuelven la parte inferior de
su corazón
se doblan y ajustan en diferentes
direcciones para empujar la sangre por
su corazón
cuando células especiales llamadas
células marcapasos generan señales
eléctricas dentro de su corazón
las células del músculo del corazón
llamadas mi ositos se contraen como
grupo
su corazón está dividido en dos mitades
derecha e izquierda que trabajan juntas
como una bomba doble sobre el lado
derecho de su corazón la sangre de shock
sigue nada de los tejidos corporales
fluye por venas grandes llamadas la vena
cava inferior y superior hasta la
aurícula derecha
luego la sangre viaja hasta el
ventrículo derecho que se contrae y
envía la sangre fuera del corazón hasta
los pulmones para recoger oxígeno y
deshacerse del dióxido de carbono sobre
el lado izquierdo de su corazón la
sangre rica en oxígeno de sus pulmones
fluye por sus venas pulmonares hasta la
aurícula izquierda la sangre luego pasa
a su ventrículo izquierdo que se contrae
y envía la sangre fuera del corazón a
través de la aorta para alimentar las
células y los tejidos
las primeras ramas de su aorta son las
arterias coronarias que ofrecen
nutrientes y oxígeno a los músculos del
corazón
en la parte superior de su aorta las
arterias se ramifican para llevar la
sangre a la cabeza y brazos
las arterias que se ramifican desde las
partes medias e inferiores de su aorta
suministran sangre al resto de su cuerpo
su corazón late un promedio de 60 a 100
latidos por minuto en ese minuto su
corazón bombea alrededor de cinco
cuartos de galón 4.7 litros de sangre
por las arterias lo que ofrece un flujo
equilibrado de oxígeno y nutrientes a
todo su cuerpo